こんにちははじめ社長です皆さん大変お待たせいたしました
ちょいな画像方は出てたと思うんですけどもベイブレードの弾み冊をモデルがついに
完成しましただけど今日はもうベイブレード公式の方たちに完成した
肇社長のレベルのを持ってきて頂いておりますどうぞどうぞ
あーこれ1 ae
魚と見で米を開発するパーサー部の張りかねぇ
された friday yeah 増加はねぇ
彼がやってみましたまだだれバーガードーン
くりかあさんはまだ一生分で行っていないそうだねそうだね一回も勝ててないだけで僕
より祝いを2人形や変 ao おかしいおかしいのか道すると皆そう思っちゃう
フェに完成したということで完成しました
ドレイクでございましたっけ半年
づらい超特急で作っていきましょう本当に上げて誰もう早速
も見てもいいですかいいですか同じ恐れだろこちらに出てきましたーー
いいコラー
ズゲートっていると
いっそございます今ちょうどショーがあるこれが肇社長モデルねええええ
愛国ラーでうっかりここに釣り冊を持てると書いてありますでいいで他の写真を使った
パッケージ
ベーグル飛ばすして初ですねほんとですかこういう学校
いろいろ手伝いをさせてくださいはい弱いとかも結構考えますてちょっと目細くほい
路面指定してこれになって10度知行は錯誤3人でしょ
1回色香が
ブービー怒っサティロスけっこうすごいロスげーっ
スコアいきましたねほんとありがとうございますでもが出来ましたとかたままを色々い
て本当に経理で作ったやつでございますこっちに強いですかちゃんと今年でしたじゃあ
ねっないでねじゃあ強い
心配だったんだ
早速開けてみていいですかどうぞうーんまぢ新品でまあ安いパーツ見ていきましょうか
ずレイヤーがですね超絶歩き戦力シュートすればなんとバーストしなくなる
ロックされるんでも僕されて相手をバスしやすいしてディスクわーワンダッシュって
いうちょっとブレって肺丸アタック旅行
強くする奴方法は本当だステータスみてくださいもう
六角形の良いがあっ意味がもう会えだけが振り切れたら右ハンド入らない超攻撃型で
長靴というか調フレームってあのディスクにつけるぷらのパーツはえーっ
ディスクに当てて相手を奪うとしてしまいからかんだもう高いが強い
あたるということですね当たるプレミがってるドライバー i バーガー実はこれは
スゴイはずですね髪髪が出ると雑種
再起動ってあの加速するドライバー昔あり持ち上げファインアートドライバーの羽根を
強くしたダッシュ板
へ初めてぜひパンはこれ着たらも館マジすか
ムスカ肇社長
出るしか入ってないうわぁ買うしかねーだろ攻撃型となっております
開けていいですかぁ工房4駅つ
[音楽]
中はハイハイハイハイやいかーんうま煮
おおおお
いやーやっぱねかっこいいぜねスローンぬ作らせていただきます
ip 結構打ってパチっとソテーしたのでということも楽しみの一つ
月
me
うおーきたできましたああああ
はい実物こんなに縦になっております ua はいこえー
かっこいいまちしロスでし真っ白兄後ろスネ墓と青が入って回転すると赤いライン加工
入るという方が
郷愁としておきだけんよ
ねえええ
表から見てもあの海での余波が出るので
ドラグーン f みたいに赤い線が外うん
週末でかっこいーがー
[音楽]
[笑い]
ブーバーれ減っておりませんってないこいつはまだ本気じゃねぇよと
見えますね
こいつの力を引き出せてない yn あ
ni
これがかっこいいんですよはいはいようにめっちゃいいしてくれ
あれば最高ですこれは動くもらっていいですかいやいや今日こちらのお店しに来た
なんか別にこれはあの売りもなんてはい
あ
買わなきゃいけないまあそうそうそうねっ
a 8
あいやーこれ僕らはあげたくないでペル社長は欲しい欲しいこれ2人はこれもう
パターンも違うでしょうだから流れだねこれは我々に買ったら教
特別に上げますやっぱデザインしたものですね前の良台ですねこれは冷蔵庫
これ使ってる人恋するそうですねお二人はもう1番2のできてください
あまーいんサリーの2の安謝じゃあまぢ勝ちます2人とも高さが大変そうだかなぁ
いや2人ともと思います
えっイース d 縄文アーサーそうですが床を倒して倒して売って同士で配っている
はっはっはっいう今からたいパタンとパッチ食器ではよろしくお願いしますよろしくお
願いします
まずは私からはいあーつかむラッキーのスカーフェリーは超絶アキレス青が同じね超絶
かつ生命デーと色でみたいなどうぞ
a で勝った人でブラキャラといえばもう回収
若い奴は絶対わけだねここはじゃないですか審判お姉ちゃんそれじゃあねぞうパー
exe
2ワンッ
抹茶攻撃ある are you doing 海外ワイフをかけてから映像を確定する
とこれは
さーああああっ
[拍手]
[笑い]
ブーバーこりゃあしくっ
連覇を池ザせください一生別持って墓地すげー苦悩木村さん通す母じゃあもう一回1回
パスびっくりしてるはずだよ
ee
があればさっき買ったんだよな
本番に強いたという会いたいことに入りますからねあっはって来たーーつげーき
うわぁアイスリーツーワン神戸市
[拍手]
ああああああああ
ああああああ
奄美ですねはじめさ超すごいじゃーんブーブーレバータックル過去じゃう過剰ですね
弾きがあんまだ
日向
ねぇ一本取られたこれはでも大丈夫なきゃ負けるとわかっ貼っただけでええ
じゃあお願いします日本冥王仲良くすごいですねもういやあこれ本当に抗議時からから
ば当たればちゃんサーブって言うねぇ
あげるつもりなかったからああヌー
夢で相性が合ってはタックタイプって
defense タイプに弱いする何
が自分が使ういえばこの最新の武神足らー
いましたーーー
新しいあり日使うシリーズがあって
いたらやばくない人これ超ヤバイ家が12枚まで相手の攻撃をいなそう
としておりますん
は言えもうぶつかっても振った
無関心層王正社長の攻撃をスルー
なるほど2皆をなくして目社長でが詰まるシーンがもうね見れますよそのシーンが
じゃあさせねえぞ
んっを守りたいっですねじゃあよしこいいいぞ
see to i do do
ただキタキターマーシャバッチリもあればうっ
いやーこれ完璧なバリアー
確実なビーム時わーおりゃー
サボり切って守り切ってー
オールぐうっ
はぁ
たかったぁー
9割がをしています
持った上嘘ねえだろこれ普通に負けちゃったんだけど俺なんか普通はや僕いい
日本一強いんですけどだけさんいやー
800もめっきりも地味なわけかさ今街で言い合っています
バッハ何がどうだったんですが台頭多様な攻撃で結構安価で焼いてくれでアースってと
抹茶草木もラバーなんで
いやー俺強くないかよいで5位は超強いから
いやーすごいこれで改造するとより強くなる可能性もあるオーナー
なるほど力ずくでビンスタイプをし破ったーーー
うこの米は俺のもんだーらー
はいというわけで弾み冊をモデル強かったいやーこれは普通かじゃあぜよ
こちらがですねと3月の30日に版13階に3枚3土曜日ではいぜひ皆さん手に入れて
みてください今日は良いはずでかっこいいねこのパッケージが腕十字ラーをあいつは
すっそしてですねはいなんと4月の5日から便利デートのシーンアニメ
テープでれるとまあそうガチガチとこうこれらが出てるやつか安寧
願いしますよあも始まるのでぜひ見てくださいねちょっと見てもらいたいものがあるん
ですけどいうことでこちらをどうぞ
おぼぼなんとなんとなんとここで世界で活躍するあーのブレーダーからの熱い
メッセージが届きましたよ
大
これはあれウェーバーなかったかあれあるいはぜと思ったねー
僕が出てまずおおぉ話してますねハピ名の一番西脇
大勢そこ好きなアニメの方もぜひチェックしてみてくださいします
31わけでまあ僕は今回勝負に勝つなんでよかったですがー
ああああ前回を買ってねーんだよなぁほんとずっとこれを使ってもっと上で明確じゃあ
これ本館すごいでかい続けてください
まずいますた上田のだよまた押して下さいじゃあ今は
よしカレー
[音楽]
me
バッハ